hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
eigentlich wollten wir hier heute an
dieser Stelle über die Stadt bachmuth
ihre Rolle im Krieg und den Zustand der
russischen Armee sprechen diese Stadt
ist ja schon lange und vor allem hart
umkämpft über die haben wir auch letzte
Woche schon berichtet darüber sprechen
wir auch gleich wir müssen aber vorher
noch unseren Blick einmal auf eine
andere Stadt wenden nämlich auf die
russische Stadt Belgorod dort soll ein
Grenzposten an der Grenze zu Ukraine
überfallen worden sein vielleicht habt
ihr die Meldung und Bilder dazu auf
Twitter heute schon gesehen hier seht
ihr einmal wo diese Stadt liegt die
liegt tatsächlich in Russland aber sehr
sehr nah an der Ukraine und lasst uns
jetzt mal gemeinsam auf die Bilder
schauen die uns heute aus dieser Stadt
erreicht haben da sehen wir nämlich
verschiedene Dinge die heute für viel
Aufruhr im Internet gesorgt haben es
gibt da verschiedene
Erklärungen hier sehen wir Helikopter
der russischen Armee die sogenannte
Täuschkörper über Belgorod abfeuern das
sind Fackeln die in die gegnerische
Raketen vom Helikopter ablenken sollen
und auch im Umland von Belgorod steigt
Rauch auf auf auch dort wird offenbar
gekämpft und diese Bilder die kam heute
also ziemlich überraschend und deswegen
wollen wir hier heute einmal über die
sprechen und das tun wir zuerst mit
unserem zdf-korrespondenten Tim Kröger
der für uns live aus saporija berichtet
hallo guten Abend Tim
schönen guten Abend jetzt gibt es ja den
ganzen Tag über schon verschiedene
erkläransätze von wem diese Angriffe
jetzt
ausging was hast du denn heute schon
dazu gehört bzw hast du schon
Informationen zu diesem Vorgang
naja also ich finde es nicht ganz
einfach das alles einzuschätzen die
ganzen Informationen die auf dem Markt
sind rund um diese Situation die da in
der Region Belgorod ganz nah an der
ukrainischen Grenze heute passiert sind
die russische Seite hat sich sehr
umfangreich dazu geäußert und zwar
werfen sie ukrainischen sabituren und
Spionen vor sozusagen auf Russisch ist
Gebiet eingedrungen zu sein und dann
eben dort Angriffe ausgeübt haben unter
anderem auch auf drei Dörfer und erst
dabei eben auch Menschen zu Schaden
gekommen sind es sind Menschen verletzt
worden das mussten auch Menschen ins in
die Krankenhäuser einen
eingebracht werden und dort behandelt
werden das ganze ist auf jeden Fall so
groß dass der russische Präsident Putin
umgehend davon informiert worden ist und
ähm das ähm auch in diesem gesamten
Bereich da in dieser ganzen Region
Terror Alarm ausgelöst worden ist und
ganz offenbar sind jetzt eben die
russischen Kräfte dabei zu versuchen
diese von ihnen ausgesehen eindringe
wieder zurück in Richtung Ukraine zu
drängen die ukrainische Führung aber hat
gesagt sie hat mit diesem Vorfällen im
Grunde nichts zu tun sie ist dafür auch
nicht verantwortlich alle Aussagen die
dazu getätigt werden können wir im
Moment nicht so ohne das weiteres
überprüfen es gibt beispielsweise auch
zwei parallelmeterische Gruppierungen
die sich dazu bekannt haben die das sind
russische Gruppierungen die ganz
offenbar auf den Seiten der Ukraine
stehen und die sagen sie selbst dort
eine Art militarisierte Zone an der
Grenze zur Ukraine einrichten wollen
damit eben diese Angriffe von russischer
Seite auf die Ukraine aufhören wie
gesagt auch das können wir nicht
wirklich nachvollziehen bzw überprüfen
Russland beispielsweise sagt dass die
ukrainische Führung durchaus etwas damit
zu tun hat und dass diese Angriffe davon
ablenken wollen sollen dass Bach Mut
gefallen ist also ja ich wiederhole es
noch einmal das ist nicht alles einfach
einzuordnen aber das ist jetzt erstmal
der Stand der Dinge die wir haben
genau tim hat es gerade schon gesagt da
ist gerade noch super viel unklar wir
werden auch nicht nur mit ihm darüber
sprechen sondern später auch noch mit
Oberst Markus Reisner vom
österreichischen Bundesheer den ihr auch
genauso wie Tim eure Fragen stellen
könnt hier im Chat oder per Mail Tim du
hast es gerade schon angesprochen der
Kreml spricht ja jetzt auch von einer
Verbindung dieser Aktion zur
ukrainischen Führung um von der
Situation in bachmut abzulenken kannst
du uns noch mal ganz kurz auf den
neuesten Stand bringen die ist diese
Situation in bachmut ja wie ist da die
aktuelle Lage
genau auch in bachmuth muss ich leider
sagen ist die Situation nicht ganz klar
es war ja so dass am Wochenende die
russische Seite für sich beansprucht hat
die Stadt komplett eingenommen zu haben
dem steht aber auf der anderen Seite
gegenüber dass die ukrainische Seite
sagt das stimmt nicht wir haben immer
noch eine kleine Ecke der Stadt in
unserer Gewalt wir bzw in unter unserer
Kontrolle und die wird auch noch von den
Truppen dort verteidigt also da steht
gegeneinander wir können auch diese
beiden Aussagen nicht überprüfen aber
ich bin mir auch gar nicht so sicher ob
das noch relevant ist ob der jetzt
wirklich die letzten Häuserblocks
innerhalb Bach Muts bereits an die
Russen gefallen sind oder ob die noch
von ukrainischen Truppen gehalten werden
ich finde es eigentlich viel wichtiger
dass man jetzt schon mal etwas in die
Zukunft guckt wie dieser Kampf in und
umbachmut weitergeht zum Beispiel die
Frage was passiert wenn der russische
Söldner Chef prigoshi seine aussagebar
Macht und seine
Truppe aus bachmut rauszieht ob das
beispielsweise die Verb Kunden oder wenn
er das dann an die reguläre russische
Truppe übergibt bedeutet das dann
womöglich dass die russischen Truppen
dort geschwächt werden also wir hören
beispielsweise auch dass die russische
Armee im Moment neue Truppen neue
Soldaten in Richtung bachmut schickt auf
der anderen Seite ist die Frage wie geht
es weiter an den Flanken von bachmut wo
ja ganz offenbar die ukrainischen
Truppen in den vergangenen Tagen
Geländegewinne gemacht haben sie sollen
da offenbar mehrere Quadratkilometer
zurückerobert haben dahinter soll
angeblich der Versuch stehen die
russischen Truppen in der Stadt von
außen einzukreisen ob das funktioniert
weiß natürlich keiner aber ich denke
wenn wir in diesen beiden Punkten bei
diesen beiden Aspekten etwas mehr
Klarheit haben dann kann man vielleicht
auch in einigen Tagen die Situation rund
um bachmut etwas besser einschätzen klar
ist eigentlich nur das einer und das
hören wir ja mittlerweile schon seit
Monaten es wird weiterhin und Umbach Mut
gekämpft das heißt es sterben auch
weiter Soldaten in dieser ohnehin schon
sehr sehr brutalen schlachten
diese Stadt bachmut und damit auch da
sehen wir noch mal wo bachmut liegt noch
mal für euch zur Einordnung ähm jetzt
wurde ja immer gesagt dass bachmut eine
strategisch sehr sehr wichtige Stadt ist
und deswegen auch so hat gekämpft wird
wie wichtig ist in diese Stadt aber noch
du hast gerade gesagt eigentlich ist gar
nicht mehr so viel von der
ursprünglichen Stadt übrig ist die
wirklich noch wichtig
also ich habe den Eindruck dass bachmut
tatsächlich mittlerweile eher zu einer
Symbol ein Symbol einem der wichtigen
starken Symbol in diesem Krieg geworden
ist an dass sich beide Seiten sehr
verbissen haben ich hatte den Eindruck
dass diese Stadt sehr lange für die
ukrainische Seite von einem strategisch
wichtigen Wert ist weil sie die Russen
die russischen Truppen in dieser Stadt
also im Häuserkampf viel besser
aufhalten konnten über viele viele
Monate in der hohe Verluste zufügen
konnten als das etwa auf dem freien Feld
möglich gewesen wäre und dass das
vielleicht auch der Grund gewesen ist
warum die Ukraine so lange in bachmut
gegengehalten haben jetzt ist es
natürlich so dass mit der Einnahme von
bachmut die russischen Truppen doch ein
kleines Stückchen näher herangekommen
sind an die beiden Städte Klammer
Thorsten und Slowenien die ja auf
ukrainischer Seite im Dornbach noch
gehalten werden und auch sozusagen so
eine Art Hauptstadt sind und auf die die
russische Seite eben auch besonders
abgesehen hat
weiß nicht ob sie das wir haben jetzt
hier wie sehr häufig Luftalarm aber das
ist eigentlich kein Grund wir können
jetzt noch kurz weiter sprechen also wie
gesagt dass das ist natürlich ein
bisschen mehr offen aber es ist doch so
dass die ukrainische Seite dich ganz
offenbar schon sehr lange ihre
Befestigungsanlagen rund um die Stadt
sozusagen ihre eigene Richtung verstärkt
haben also von vielen Beobachtern wird
der strategische Wert von bachmut als
nicht einmal so hoch angesehen
ja und wir berichten über ZDF heute live
die letzten Wochen vielleicht auch schon
fast die letzten Monate auch immer
wieder über die ukrainische
Frühjahrsoffensive einige sagen die
läuft schon andere sagen die kündigt
sich jetzt gerade noch an ähm was
bedeutet jetzt Bach Mut oder dieser
aktuelle Stand vom bachmut für die
früher als Offensive die vielleicht noch
kommt und was bedeutet auch der Ort an
dem du gerade stehst nämlich saporicja
für diese früher als Offensive
also die Frage ist ja ob diese Vorstöße
seitens der Ukraine an den Flanken vom
bachmut womöglich schon mal ein erster
Vorgeschmack auf diese Offensive gewesen
sein konnten
ich gehe eigentlich davon aus dass die
ukrainische Armee eine Schwachstelle auf
Seiten der Russen dort ausgemacht hat
und die eben diese eben ausgenutzt hat
aber das natürlich eben versucht wird in
bachmut möglichst viele russische
Truppen zu binden die dann eben dann
anderer Stelle zur Verteidigung fehlen
es wird nach wie vor von vielen
Beobachtern und ich teile das eigentlich
auch davon ausgegangen dass vor allem
ein Vorstoß hier bei saporicia möglich
ist weil von hier aus könnte man
Richtung südenvorstoßen ohne über den
Fluss niebro der dann in Richtung Süden
die ähm so eine eine so eine Art ja
praktisch schon seine Schranke oder
sowas für einen für militärische
Aktionen bildet weil sich da die beiden
Truppen russische ukrainische genau
gegenüber an den Ufern stehen also hier
könnte sondern ohne diesen Fluss
Vorstößen könnt ihr dann direkt runter
zur Stadt melittopol vorstoßen wenn das
dann von der Kampfkraft der ukrainischen
Truppen her überhaupt möglich ist aber
wenn man das erreichen würde dann hätte
man eben sehr schnell die Landverbindung
zwischen der Krim und Russland selbst
unterbrochen und das wäre natürlich
militärisch schon ein großer Erfolg also
es wird vermutet dass das eine der
hauptstoßrichtungen sein könnte es gab
in den vergangenen Wochen immer wieder
die Frage danach wie weit ist es mit den
Waffenlieferungen wie gut sind die neuen
bataione die offenbar extra für diese
Offensive aufgestellt worden sind wie
gut ist es mit der Ausbildung dieser
Truppen wie sieht es mit munitions
Nachschub aus nicht zuletzt auch wie ist
das Wetter weil der Untergrund hier in
dieser Region sehr schlammig wird im
Frühjahr das ist schlecht für gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge ist der schon genug
durchgetrocknet das sind alles Parade
Meter von dem wir nicht wissen wie weit
sie fortgeschritten sind und wann diese
Offensive denn dann wirklich kommt das
können ein paar Tage sein das können
aber auch vielleicht noch zwei drei
Wochen oder noch mehr ere Wochen sein
ja ob in ein paar Tagen oder ein paar
Wochen ich bin mir sicher wir werden mit
dir noch mal zur aktuellen Situation
sprechen vielen Dank erstmal alles Gute
für dich
ja und wir wollen ja heute eigentlich
einen Blick auf das bigger picture
werfen auf den Zustand der russischen
Armee und dazu haben wir als gastobers
Markus Reißner vom österreichischen
Bundesheer bei uns der uns jetzt live
zugeschaltet ist aus dem ZDF-Studio in
Wien hallo und guten Abend
guten Abend
Herr Reisner auch mit ihnen möchte ich
natürlich noch mal über diese Bilder aus
Belgorod sprechen die ja heute auf jeden
Fall Twitter beherrscht haben und heißt
diskutiert werden wir haben es eben
gesehen wir haben russische
Helikopter gesehen es hat geraucht was
ist denn ihr Stand der Informationen
oder was sind ihre Einschätzung was da
heute in Russland passiert ist
ja tatsächlich wird man es erst in einem
gewissen Abstand zu deiner Ereignissen
tatsächlich sagen können was hier
passiert ist was wir sehen ist natürlich
die Bilder aus den sozialen Netzwerken
von beiden Seiten und wir sehen auf der
einen Seite das offensichtlich in einem
räumlich begrenzten Ort mehr oder
weniger ist dazu gekommen ist dass die
russische Seite so sagt sie zumindest
greift isoliert hat über die Grenze
gekommen sind und dass sie hier
Kampfflugzeuge Hubschrauber aber auch
Panzer einsetzt und diese Bekämpfung zu
können
dieses Ereignis hat uns natürlich wieder
vor Augen geführt dass der Krieg vor
allem auch im Krieg im Informationsraum
ist und das nun beide Seiten versuchen
diese Ereignisse in ihrem Sinne zu
deuten auf der einen Seite wissen wir
dass die Ukraine versucht da und auch
versucht hat in der letzten Monaten
unter anderem mit Drohnen aber auch mit
Sabotage Aktionen in Russland zu setzen
und auch den Krieg nach Russland zu
tragen denn der Krieg wieder zur Zeit
immer nur die Ukraine getragen und auf
der anderen Seite wissen wir das
russland versucht natürlich das für ihre
Propaganda auszunutzen sprich ja der
große vaterländische Krieg 2.0 angefert
Russland direkt bezüglich der
Urheberschaft muss man glaube ich noch
vorsichtig sein denken Sie an Ereignisse
die wir im Gremium hatten vor kurzem mit
den Drohnenangriffen wo auch bis heute
nicht klar ist da wer was beide Seiten
können Interesse daran haben
zu zeigen man kann Russland auch tief im
ersten Treffen und die russische Seite
und möglicherweise das relativ der
Bevölkerung wir werden angegriffen
gegriffen entsprechend verstärken zu
können
ja und danke erstmal für diese erste
Einschätzung ich werfe gerade mal einen
Blick in die Kommentare ob es schon
Fragen gibt wenn ihr da draußen Fragen
an Herrn Reißner habt dann schickt sie
uns gerne in den Chat oder per Mail an
die eingeblendete Adresse ich werfe mal
einen Blick rein und es gibt natürlich
viele Fragen zu dem Thema auch wenn viel
davon wie sie schon sagen gerade noch
spekulatives ich stelle trotzdem mal
eine Frage und wir gucken mal inwiefern
die beantwortet werden kann Daniel
Wendler auf Youtube fragt wäre es
möglich dass die Ukraine ein Stück
Russland erobert und um dann Land zum
Tauschen zu haben ist das ein
realistisches Szenario
das ist das jetziger Sicht da kein
realistisches Szenario denn dazu brachte
die Ukraine signifikant Kräfte die
Ukraine hat zurzeit Kräfte
zusammengezogen für diese geplante
Offensive die sogenannten Brigaden der
Offensive 12 Stück an der Zahl von
zwischen dreieinhalb bis 5.000 Mann man
würde durch den Versuch quasi Teile
Russlands im Besitz zu nehmen diese
Kräfte quasi in einer Art und Weise
einsetzen mir sicher nicht dienlich ist
nämlich dem Zweck quasi das ukrainische
Direktorium wieder von der russischen
besatzungs-truppen frei zu bekommen und
man würde natürlich Russland da in einer
Art und Weise angreifen wie es
möglicherweise bis jetzt nicht passiert
ist und Russland würde vielleicht dann
noch andere Maßnahmen setzen die wir
jetzt gar nicht voraussehen können und
da ist natürlich schon auch interessant
wenn man betrachtet die letzten Monate
dass gerade auf dem Oktober letzten
Jahres Russland war mit dieser
strategischen luftkampagne nach wie vor
die Ukraine sehr schwer treffen kann und
die Ukraine die Unterstützung des
Westens braucht ihr vor allem der
Flieger werden und dem entgegenhalten zu
können das heißt ich denke die Ukraine
wird da tun nichts vermeiden das zu tun
sondern wird versuchen Ihre Gäste zu
bündeln für diese bevorstehende
Offensive
ja und wahrscheinlich ist es für mehr
Gespräch dazu jetzt gerade auch einfach
noch zu früh das sind trotzdem mal erste
Einschätzung für euch zu diesen Bildern
die ihr heute bestimmt schon auf Social
Media gesehen habt wir wollen jetzt noch
mal einen Blick auf das bigger picture
werfen und auf die Frage ob der Westen
die Stärke der russischen Armee jetzt
lange unterschätzt hat und der Anlass
dafür ist eine Analyse des britischen
Think Tanks Rosi die dem russischen
Militär Lernfähigkeit bescheinigt und
auch sagt da werden gerade Panzer und
Luftwaffen geschont für einen späteren
Einsatz und sie erreichen sie sehen das
ja recht ähnlich wie diese Analyse
die russische Armee hat ja wir haben es
gerade schon gehört zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich große Teile von
bachmut eingenommen und einige waren
davon überrascht das heißt aber sie
wahrscheinlich nicht so oder
das herausforderte daran ist dass ich
auch immer wieder darauf hingewiesen hat
dass man die russische Armee nicht
unterschätzen soll das schade dass
meiner Sicht der Ukrainer mehr als es
ihnen hilft oder wenn wir quasi die
russische Armee meines Lächerliche
ziehen und nicht verstehen dass das auch
ein ganz gezielter Teil des Kampfes im
Informationsraum ist der von Ihnen
angesprochene russische Bericht ist
tatsächlich der vierte Bericht der zu
diesem Thema erscheint und auch die
anderen Berichte haben ein sehr
nüchternes Bild gezeichnet und haben
klar dargestellt dass er die russischen
Streitkräfte zwar schwerwiegende Fehler
machen aber sie immer wieder in der Lage
sind sich anzupassen und was man sehr
gut erkennen kann ist das immer dann
wenn die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
beweglich waren sehr erfolgreich waren
aber wenn die russischen Streitkräfte es
geschafft haben den Ukraine einen
Stellungskrieg aufzuzwingen und das ist
mittlerweile das zweite Mal der Fall
dann können die russischen Streitkräfte
ihre großen Fähigkeiten auch spielen und
das ist der Einsatz von massiven
Waffensystemen und Raketenwerfern es ist
auch der Bereich der kampfführungen im
elektromagnetischen Feld also stören von
Drohnen und so weiter und so fort die
Bericht sagt zum Beispiel dass die
Ukraine im Monat ca 10.000 Drohnen
verlieren durch den Einsatz dieser
Kampfmittel und es zeigt dass er die
Russen sehr wohl in der Lage sind sich
anzupassen und für uns bedeutet das dass
die Ukraine in einer Art und Weise
unterstützt werden musste über das
hinaus etwas bereits getan wird
ja und wenn wir jetzt über diese Analyse
sprechen wollen und sie auch diskutieren
wollen mit Euch da draußen
müssen wir natürlich noch ein bisschen
mehr wissen was da genau festgestellt
wurde und an welchen Stellschrauben
intern bei der russischen Armee gedreht
wurde und das hat Carsten heckes für uns
zusammengefasst
Bilder aus dem vergangenen Jahr ein
Ukrainer schleppt mit seinem Traktor
einen eroberten russischen Panzer ab
Sehnen wie diese und schwere Niederlagen
gegen die Ukraine lassen die russische
Armee lange Zeit schwach wirken manche
Experten gehen sogar von einer baldigen
Niederlage aus doch eine Studie des
unabhängigen Forschungsinstituts für
Sicherheitsfragen dem Royal United
Services Institute zeigt russland hat
sein Kriegsbeginn dazu gelernt
Panzer werden besser verborgen die
Artillerie wird beweglicher kann so
gezielter angreifen und sich besser vor
Gegenschlägen schützen und die in
effektive Luftwaffe bleibt am Boden
stattdessen setzt Moskau immer häufiger
Kamikaze Drohnen iranischer Bauart ein
zusätzlich wird Russland in der
Verteidigung stärker setzt vermehrt auf
Familie und fällt Befestigungen auch die
Luft Verteidigung hat ihre Effizienz
gesteigert immer häufiger gelingt es
sogar Heimat Raketen abzufangen doch
Werbebanden in der Moskauer Innenstadt
zeigen Russland fehlen motivierte
Soldaten die Moral an der Front laut
Studie Russlands größte Schwäche
ja Thema Moral das ist ja ein Thema was
die russische Armee schon lange
beschäftigt ist das auch ein Problem was
die ukrainische Armee mittlerweile
eingeholt hat gerade in so einer
Situation in der wir uns gerade befinden
Stichwort bachmut
ja vielleicht kommt es noch kurz
einordnen zu können ja um da zu Moral
eine entsprechende Aussage zu treffen
sie dürfen nicht vergessen dass die
russischen Streitkräfte mit einer für
das Land gemessenen geringen oder zu
geringen Anzahl an Soldaten
einmarschiert sind diese knapp zwischen
150 und 200.000 Mann nach dem Schock des
abwehrer Volkes durch die Ukraine hat
Russland versucht sich anzupassen und
die erstmals Name war durch das
einberufen von Reservisten neue Kräfte
heranzuführen die waren natürlich nicht
vergleichbar mit dem Berufssoldaten und
haben natürlich eine geringere Moral
gehabt da und das so wirkt natürlich bis
heute nach trotzdem und da gibt es auch
die Aussage vom Kommandanten durch
Streitkräfte in Europa genau kaviole hat
Russland geschafft da die Truppenstärke
von 350 bis 400.000 Mann anzusteigen und
es steht im Raum dass jetzt der neue
Kontakt Nicki zu laufen das in dieser ca
120.000 Soldaten die aus der Wehrpflicht
heraus was eine Vertrag unterschrieben
haben wo man also annehmen kann weil sie
ja freiwillig kommen dass möglicherweise
die mal wieder höher ist das ist ja
vielleicht noch zum Verständnis auf der
ukrainischen Seite
sehen wir natürlich ganz eindeutig der
Kampf zu Befreiung des eigenen Landes
der also hier sehr anspannend wirkt wir
haben die Erfolge von Kiew zum Beispiel
Erfolge von haggiv oder Person das hat
natürlich sehr viel bewirkt aber das
Problem ist natürlich auch die Städte
Abnutzung und wir haben wenn es mehr
erlaubt ist durchaus einen Vergleiche
mit dem Ersten Weltkrieg und nämlich mit
dem Jahr 1915 wo also nachdem die Elite
gefallen ist im Jahr 1914 bis Anfang 15
es dazu gekommen ist dass der Krieg
Formen Krieg der Reservisten geworden
ist das heißt auf beiden Seiten sind
sich die 14-Jährige die 40-jährigen
Familienväter gegenüber gestanden und
das ist natürlich auch im Falle der
Ukraine so dass es auch hier die Moral
Scheins nachlässt aber man natürlich
versucht die entgegen zu halten und die
Frage ist natürlich auf lange Sicht wie
wird sich das ausgehen dass auf der
einen Seite 145 Millionen folgt nämlich
Russland das gegen 35 Millionen Volk
wenn man eine geflüchteten weggerechnet
kämpft da ist die Moral zwar auf
druckländischen Seite enorm höher und
auf der russischen scheinen sich viele
fahren die Reservisten zu fragen warum
aber die Schere Masse und es nicht
bereit sein also einzusehen auf
russische Seite das ist keinen Sinn
macht zeigt natürlich dass dieser Krieg
möglicherweise noch lange dauert und
dass er noch viele Opfer fordern wird
ja Stichwort Masse und menschlicher
Verlust den wir da ja seit Ewigkeiten
seit über einem Jahr jetzt schon
beobachten hier fragt jemand aus der
Community wie viele russische Soldaten
müssen sterben oder in Gefangenschaft
sein bis Russland zurückrudert hat man
da schon mal irgendwas aus dem Kreml
vernommen wo gesagt wurde da ist
vielleicht irgendwo ein Schlussstrich zu
ziehen
nein hier gibt es ja keinerlei Aussage
von der russischen Seite wenn man die
sogenannte russische strategische Kultur
betrachtet doch so ist es so dass in
Zeiten der Krise das Volk enger zum
terranen steht und sich vom tiranen
erwartet dass er es durch die Krise
führt im Wesentlichen es gibt zu den
Verlusten eine aus meiner Sicht der
zitierbare Angabe das ist die Aussage
von
us-generalstoff-markt Miele der damals
nach dem Erfolg der Ukraine bei Person
gesagt hat dass die russische Seite
100.000 Mal an Tod und Verwöhnung
erlitten hat und auch die ukrainische
Seite ca 100.000 Mal am Boden verbunden
erlitten hat er hat damals angedeutet
dass möglicherweise der Siegburger Sohn
für Verhandlung genutzt werden sollte
den man nicht der Fall der Punkt ist das
solange Russland bereit ist der neue
Soldaten an die Frauen zu schicken
solange diese quasi gegen die
ukrainischen Soldaten kämpfen solange
kann man nicht davon ausgehen dass
Russland in die Knie geht und sich
möglicherweise zurückzieht und das ist
das Dilemma auch in der jetzigen
Situation dass die Ukraine immer wieder
neu gezwungen ist neuverbände
aufzustehen diese dann in den Einzug
schicken muss und darum auch die große
Hoffnung dass diese offensiv jetzt
durchschlägt und möglicherweise einen
einen entscheidenden Erfolg hat zwingt
der die Russen dann zumindest zum
einsehen bringt oder auch nicht das ist
die große Frage die ihnen die Historiker
beantworten werden in ein paar Jahren
aber jetzt zurzeit können wir das so
nicht voraussehen
lassen Sie uns noch mal auf die
Stichpunkte gucken die da gerade in dem
erklärstück angesprochen wurden wir
haben gehört russische Panzer seien
nicht mehr so sichtbar die russische
Artillerie habe sich verbessert und die
Befehlskette in der russischen Armee
sein nicht mehr so hierarchisch wie Sie
das einmal war kann man denn irgendwie
sagen was da ganz konkret der Auslöser
war seit wann sich diese Veränderung in
der russischen Armee abzeichnen
also der Punkt ist natürlich im
Wesentlichen dass wir wenn man die
beiden Streitkräfte vergleichen klar
sagen müssen dass die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte unter anderem auch durch
die Ausbildungen in den letzten acht
Jahren durch eine autostaaten es
geschafft hat vor allem im Sinne der
Auftragstaktik zu handeln das heißt das
Verstehen dessen was das übergeordnete
Kommando will und das umsetzen was sie
nach Verein am Essen gewesen auf der
anderen Seite die russische Armee die
sehr zentralistisch agiert wo sie so
nicht gewollt ist dass jemand
selbstständig Entscheidungen trifft
möglicherweise unmittelbar in der
Situation das Gefechts aber nicht quasi
wenn es darum geht größere Verbände zu
führen die Verluste der Russen waren und
sind enorm und das hat natürlich dazu
geführt dass vor allem die Unterführer
aber auch quasi die Vorgesetzten
Kompanie Bataillon als hungermaßen
begonnen haben sich anzupassen und viele
Taktiken hervorgeholt haben die wir
eigentlich zum Teil aus der Zeit des
Zweiten Weltkrieges kennen also zum
Beispiel das Bild von kleinen
sturmgruppen die dann was im Häuserkampf
Vorgehen der Einsatz von Artillerie die
rasche Abstimmung des heranholen des
Feuers auf unterschiedliche Ebene aber
auch zum Beispiel moderne Waffensysteme
das Problem ist dass die Ukraine ein
großes hat beim Einsatz von russischen
kamikazedonen das sind sogenannte
landsitzdrohnen die täglich sind wir ein
zwei Videos artilleriesysteme zu stören
oder Systeme und daran erkennt man das
die Russen sehr wohl in der Lage sind
sich anzupassen verheerend ist die
Situation auch im sogenannten
elektromagnetischen Feld also da wo es
um stören geht zum Beispiel wo man auch
aus dem Bericht herausnehmen kann dass
die Kommunikation der Ukraine das
vorhandene motorola-netz offensichtlich
von der großen gehackt worden ist bzw
auch der Umstand das gerade diese
Drohnen die ganz wichtig sind für die
ukrainische Aufklärung offensichtlich
geschämt werden das ist also das
englische englische Wort für stören und
dazu es kommt dass diese abstürzen und
das sieht man natürlich dass die Russen
zwar Fehler machen aber sich anpassen
und nach dieser Zeit des Krieges
offensichtlich in der Lage sind in
dieser stationären Einsatzführung
Erfolge zu haben das heißt aber noch
nicht dass sie auch in der Lage sind
jetzt wieder operative Maßnahmen
durchzuführen also möglicherweise sind
Offensive zu gehen das sieht man zurzeit
noch nicht
ja dieser Bericht sagt ja unter einem
unter anderem auch einen sehr sehr
starker Teil der russischen Armee sein
eben die russischen Ingenieure die eben
Schutzwälder etc bauen da haben wir hier
bei ZDF heute live auch schon darüber
berichtet über z.B Drachenzähne was ist
die Qualität dieser russischen
Ingenieure was gelingt da gut
also man weiß natürlich aufgrund der
vorlagenden aufklärungsbilder sehr genau
wie diese russischen Stellungen sich
darstellen man sieht dass sie quasi den
Grundsätzen der militärischen
Verteidigungsstellungen entsprechen es
gibt also hier Panzergräben die also die
Panzer zwingen sollen zu halten um sie
dann in das Feuer von Panzer
verlinkwaffen zum Beispiel zu bringen es
gibt diese von Ihnen angesprochenen
Drachenzähne die es auch den Erfolg des
Helmen
es gibt Minenfelder wo man also versucht
quasi durch eine Kanalisierung die
angreifenteile hinein zu locken es gibt
Bunkerstellungen die verbunden sind mit
schweren Waffen und so weiter und so
fort ja die Geschichte hat gezeigt dass
derartige Verteidigungslinien oft groß
angekündigt worden sind aber oft nicht
durchgehalten haben denken Sie an die
maschinelline oder denken Sie auch an
den Atlantik weil die metaxislinien
Griechenland und viele andere Beispiele
der Punkt ist aber dass die Ukraine
natürlich eine Herausforderung hat und
das ist die nicht vorhandene eigene
Luftwaffe darum auch die Forderung nach
den 16 Kampfflugzeugen denn natürlich
mit einer eigenen Luftwaffe wäre es
möglich diese Stellungen vorzubereiten
also gezielt Stützpunkte anzugreifen
und die Voraussetzungen zu schaffen für
einen vormarsteigenden Kräfte das Weite
ist natürlich das vorhandene
pioniergerät man braucht also hier
Minenräumen Panzer man braucht
brückenlegepanzer um diese Stellungen zu
überwinden und darum ist der Moment der
Überraschung und Täuschung so wichtig
damit die Ukraine schafft diese
Stellungen zu durchbrechen das kann
gelingen kann aber auch scheitern auch
hier wird man sehen wie die nächsten
Wochen und Monate sich dann darstellen
und ob es gelingt dann entscheidender
Stelle einen Durchbruch zu erzielen der
möglicherweise dann einen Erfolg für die
Ukraine möglich macht so wie das bei
Personen gesehen ist bei Haki oder zuvor
Thema Luftwaffen bzw fehlende Luftwaffen
der Ukraine zwei Fragen dazu jetzt hat
er am Wochenende haben die USA und
andere Nato-Partner diese F 16 Jets
zugesagt von denen sie gesprochen haben
wie läuft das denn jetzt ab könnten
überhaupt noch schnell genug in die
Ukraine kommen um in dieser früher als
Offensive wo niemand so richtig weiß hat
sie schon begonnen in leichten Teilen
wird sie noch noch stärker wirklich
loslegen können diese F 16 Jets da
überhaupt einen impact haben
hier lassen sie uns ganz kurz auf die
Offensive eingehen eine offensives
militärische sich besteht immer aus drei
Phasen die erste Phase ist die
sogenannte Vorbereitungsphase hier
versuchen sie den Gegner so zu schwächen
dass wenn sie dann angreifen und das ist
dann die entscheidende Phase die zweite
Phase sind entsprechend rasch
durchbrechen können und dann in einer
dritten Phase das gewonnene Gelände zu
halten und sich zu konsolidieren wir
sehen dass die erste Phase begonnen hat
die Ukraine versucht auch unter den
Einsatz von der weitreichenden Drohnen
Treibstoff die Bose anzugreifen
Verkehrsknotenpunkte anzugreifen sie
versucht zu sontieren und zu schauen wo
in diesen russischen
Verteidigungsstellungen sind Lücken wo
sie quasi ansetzen können und sie
versuchen auch zum Teil fliegen Abwehr
nach vorne zu bringen in dessen Schutz
dann quasi die veranstalt Kräfte sich
bereitstellen können wenn es günstiger
scheint kann man von dieser ersten Phase
in die zweite kommen wenn es nicht
günstig erscheint kann man das natürlich
in die Länge ziehen das heißt die zweite
Phase kann auch möglicherweise erst in
ein paar Monaten passieren damit sie mir
jetzt bei der Frage der Kampfflugzeuge
Kampfflugzeuge sind natürlich ungleich
Komplex in der Ausbildung als z.B ein
Kampfpanzer der selbst auch eine
Herausforderung bereits darstellt und
man ist dass sie so natürlich hier
erstens Piloten verwendet werden die
also bereits eine gewisse Vorausbildung
haben die zum Beispiel auf der Mic 29
geflogen sind oder auf einer su24 aber
trotzdem die Technik ist natürlich ein
gewaltiger Unterschied das wäre so wie
wenn sie aus einem Lader Taiga quasi in
einen Tesla umsteigen sie müssen das
eine Reihe von Dingen hier
berücksichtigen und bedienen können und
da ist die Expertenmeinung das ist
zwischen vier und sechs Monaten braucht
um ein gewisses Ausbildungsniveau zu
bekommen dann können Sie die Maschine
steuern können Sie die Waffen einsetzen
aber es geht da dran auch darum im
Verbund entsprechend wirksam zu werden
und Sie dürfen nicht vergessen dass auf
der anderen Seite die russischen Piloten
auch entsprechende Erfahrung gesammelt
haben und auch ein ernst zu nehmen
dagegen sein werden das heißt die Frage
wird jetzt Zeit für die Ukraine wartet
sie ab und auf diese neue Fähigkeiten
zurückzugreifen oder riskiert sie die
Offensive und der hofft dass sie dann
die Kampfflugzeuge ist auch möglich
machen dann im weiteren Folge vor allem
eine Abwehrkampf weiter zu führen gegen
Russland aber vor allem auch die Tiefe
des Landes Stichwörter Drohnenangriff
aufgrund dieser strategischen
luftkompete Russen entsprechen D der
sichern zu können
ja und wenn wir schon mal bei der
Definition solche militärischen Begriffe
sind mit denen wir ja gerade fast
tagtäglich hantieren da gibt's noch eine
Frage aus der Community dazu und zwar
fragt ein User auf Youtube alle sprechen
von der Großoffensive auf der
ukrainischen Seite aber kann man ohne
Lufthoheit mit sehr kleiner schwacher
Luftwaffe überhaupt eine klassische
Großoffensive starten
genau das ist das große Dilemma dass ich
hier natürlich stellt es gibt hier ein
sehr schönes Beispiel aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg denken Sie an die Landung der
Streitkräfte in der Normandie diese
Landung wurde in den Wochen und Monaten
ganz gezielt durch die alliierte
Luftwaffe vorbereitet man hat also hier
Brücken zerstört man hat
Verkehrsknotenpunkte angegriffen man hat
alles unternommen um zu verhindern dass
dann am tag der Landung die
bereitgestellten deutschen
Panzerdivisionen rasch nach vorne kommen
und dann quasi die angelandeten Kräfte
wieder ins Meer zurückwerfen und eine
ähnliche Situation haben wir hier wir
haben also klar die Absicht eine
offensive durchzuführen aber es fällt
dieses Element quasi der Einsatzführung
aus der Luft jetzt ist es so dass in der
modernen Kriegsführung durchaus durch
den Einsatz von Polizisten
Waffensystemen man das kompensieren kann
aber natürlich ca 100 bis 150
Kampfflugzeugen mit entsprechender
Bewaffnung haben natürlich einen ganz
anderen Effekt als einige wenige die
immer wieder in der Lage sind
spektakulär zum Beispiel die Storm
einzusetzen so wie wir das in der
letzten Tagen zumindest sieben Mal
gesehen haben aber die Masse fehlt hier
die so wichtig ist und beginnen
Offensive
überraschungs und täuschungseffekt zu
ziehen und schnell durchzubrechen und
das ist der Moment die Ukraine hat also
dieses Momentum am Beginn und das muss
sie nutzen in der Absicht einen Art
Domino oder kaskadeneffekt zu ziehen wie
das bei haargift gelungen ist der dazu
führt dass quasi das russische
verteidigungsdis positiv zusammenbricht
und die Soldaten zurückfluten das wäre
genau der Effekt die Magazin möchte und
da ist das natürlich so dass eine
funktionierende potente Luftwaffe für
einen wesentlichen Unterschied macht
ja lassen Sie uns vielleicht noch mal
bei der ukrainischen Armee bleiben hier
fragt jemand auf Youtube wie hoch waren
denn die ukrainischen Verluste in
bachmut also wir haben jetzt gehört so
steht es um die russische Armee sie
scheinbar besser ausgerüstet als gedacht
wie steht's jetzt aber nach dieser
langen Schlacht um bachmut um die
ukrainische Armee
ja diese Frage werden wir auch erst in
der Nachschau beantworten können
möglicherweise erst in ein paar Jahren
wenn er so alle Daten vorliegen die
einen Analyse zulassen sie sehen jetzt
natürlich das momentan der Kampf um die
Deutung so heute losgebrochen ist als
auf der einen Seite die Russen die sagen
wir haben paar gute eingenommen und
haben den Ukraine schwerste Verluste
dabei gebracht auf der anderen Seite die
Ukraine die sagt wir haben den Russen
schwerste Verluste gebracht und wir sind
die Gewinner und das haben die Russen
gewonnen aus dem Berg war
Quadratkilometer Land im Wesentlichen ja
man weiß dass beide Seiten massiver
Kräfte herangeführt haben als war so
dass nach den offensiven behaarte von
Person bereits letztes Jahr auch ein
möglicher Vorstoß aus dem raumschi
Richtung Süden geplant war aufgrund des
Abzugs der russischen drucken bei Person
ich nenne das das russische den Kirchen
weiß möglich diese Kräfte unter anderem
im Park einzusetzen Luft an der Kräfte
und auch Wagner und du die Ukraine war
gefordert diesen starken Druck
entgegenzuhalten und hatte so begonnen
immer wieder ein paar Trillionen also 4
500 Soldaten nach den anderen Nachbar
Mut zu verlegen wo sie diesen russischen
Druck versucht haben entgegen zu halten
das heißt es hätte vielleicht
möglicherweise schon früher eine
offensive gegeben wenn der Druck der
Russen bei Park Mut nicht so stark
geworden ist ja fakt ist aber dass das
Ziel dass die Russen sich gesetzt haben
nämlich den kompletten Oblast und jetzt
einzunehmen bei weitem noch nicht
erfüllt ist sie haben jetzt zwar in der
zweiten Verteidigungslinie die Stadtpark
Mut eine wichtigen Stützpunkt
eingenommen aber dahinter folgen die
ersten Verteidigungsstellungen bei
chassoff ja und eine noch stärker
ausgebaute Verteidigungsstellung immer
Raum westlich davon und das bedeutet
dass das Ziel dass die Russen sich
gesetzt haben noch in weiter Ferne liegt
und das ist es auch hier gilt Kilometer
für Kilometer vor zu marschieren und
wenn das in diesem Tempo weitergeht dann
ist die Frage ob die russische Armee in
der Art und Weise wie sich das
vorgenommen hat doch tatsächlich das
schaffen kann
lassen sie uns nochmal auf die Stadt
bachmut gucken über die haben jetzt viel
gesprochen mein Kollege tim hat auch
schon gesagt so richtig viel ist von der
Stadt eigentlich gar nicht mehr übrig
und hier fragt auch jemand auf der
Community was bringt das eigentlich das
Russland jetzt bachmut erobert hat wenn
von der Stadt nichts mehr übrig ist sie
haben ja auch gesagt es handelt sich
weiterhin weiterhin um einen strategisch
wichtigen Stützpunkt
genau da muss man verstehen dass
russische narrativ das ist hier in den
Tag gelegt wird die Russen sagen sie
führen eine Demilitarisierung der
Ukraine durch das heißt die
russenargumentieren ihr vorgehen damit
dass sie die Ukraine zwingen immer
wieder neue Reserven die Front zu
bringen wo sie dann durch den Einsatz
dieser russischen verheeren
artilleriewaffen und Raketenwerfer
zerstört werden das Ergebnis sehen Sie
dann auf den Bildern das sind nicht nur
Städte wie backt Mut sind auch Städte
wie auf die FK es ist Städte wie UKE da
oder auch marienkammer gerade die Bilder
aus marienka sind also völliga
unglaublich vergleichbar quasi mit
Situationen wie wir das aus dem Ersten
Welt gekennzeichnete Landschaft und da
hintergrund ist der dass die Russen was
ich hier versuchen im stellungskriegt
die Fähigkeiten auszuspielen wo sie
immer noch den Ukrainern überlegen sind
und das ist dieser massive Einsatz von
Artillerie Systemen wo sie versuchen die
Ukraine abzunutzen und darum ist es so
wichtig für die Ukraine in die Offensive
zu kommen um aus diesem verheerenden
Stellungskrieg auszubrechen etwas was
wir genau gleich auch im Ersten
Weltkrieg erlebt haben damals war es
unter anderem auch die Entwicklung des
Panzers die dazu geführt hat dass man
aus dieser stationären Bewegung in eine
bewegungskriegsführung gekommen ist und
ähnliches sehen wir jetzt gerade auch an
der Situation von Mut auf die FK und
geht auch an anderen Orten
ja wir haben noch eine Frage aus der
Community die sich noch mal um das
Innenleben der russischen Armee kümmert
und zwar ist die Frage ist die Rhetorik
vom wagner-anführer also von Herrn
prikosin schon einen Anzeichen für die
Schwierigkeiten die sie zum Beispiel in
bachmund haben diese Frage zielt
wahrscheinlich darauf ab dass
wagnerführer prigoshi angekündigt hat
dass er seine Wagner Truppen aus der
Stadt zurückziehen wird
ja es gibt in der russischen
oder auch in der russischen Kultur des
Militär aus einem Begriff dann in sich
Maske rafka es ist der Begriff der steht
für Überraschung und Täuschung das ist
man versucht im Gegner etwas
vorzugaukeln in der Absicht ihn zu
täuschen und wenn man jetzt der
brigochien ansieht und dass es in der
letzten Wochen und Tagen immer wieder
gesagt hat so muss man feststellen dass
offensichtlich auch das hier angewandt
worden ist weil es war nicht so dass er
die Dinge die angekündigt hat er noch
umgesetzt hat im Wesentlich ja
interessant ist auch z.B also zwar ging
ja rassimo von schuldge wettert hat aber
nie gegen Putin Wetter hat und Putin vor
kurzem Wagner gratuliert hat zu diesem
Erfolg ja im backmodus das heißt man
muss es ja jetzt da abwarten was
tatsächlich passiert in den nächsten
Tagen ob Wagner was sie sich wirklich
kennt sich zurückzieht ob es seine
Übergabe an die russischen Streitkräfte
kommt und was die Rolle von Wagner ist
sie dürfen nicht vergessen wenn wir
diesen Krieg auch ein bisschen
vergleichen mit einem Spiel wie Risiko
ohne dass jetzt quasi ins Lächerliche zu
ziehen aber nur in eine Idee dazu zu
geben so wissen Sie ja dass bei diesem
Spiel ist darum geht Soldaten Figuren in
verschiedenen Regionen zu platzieren und
wir sehen jetzt natürlich immer auf das
was in der Ukraine passiert aber wer hat
das so mitbekommen dass gerade auch
Wagner durchaus globalen Einfluss ausübt
wie zum Beispiel Afrika denn in der Zeit
wo quasi die Spielfiguren in der Ukraine
sich bewegt haben hat Russland es
geschafft durch Wagner Spielfiguren zu
platzieren in Mali zum Beispiel im
Burkina Faso und auch in Libyen und das
hat natürlich eine Bedeutung das heißt
man muss es auch hier diese globale
Rolle von Wagner entsprechend betonen
und die Herausforderung die sich dazu
für uns gibt denn wenn es es Wagner und
damit russlandschaft z.B dieser heilzone
zu kontrollieren dann hat es natürlich
einen unmittelbaren Einfluss auf Europa
Stichwort Migrationsbewegungen und so
weiter und so fort
ja lassen Sie uns zum Abschluss
vielleicht noch mal zusammenfassen die
russische Armee scheint also besser
ausgestattet besser aufgestellt als
jetzt lange gedacht dazu die Situation
in bachmut was glauben Sie oder wie
schätzen Sie ein dass die ukrainische
Armee jetzt darauf reagieren wird was
wird sie vielleicht an ihrer Taktik an
ihrer Strategie ändern um darauf zu
reagieren
ukrainische Armee hat es geschafft
trotzdem starken Drucks der Russen im
Park Mut ihre entscheidenden Reserven
die sie für die Offensive bereitgestellt
hat noch nicht einzusetzen wir können
das ganz gut daran erkennen dass wir in
diesen Aufnahmen noch aus den sozialen
Netzwerken der Kämpfe in Bad Mutters im
Norden und im Süden noch keine Fahrzeuge
sehen die quasi für diese Brigaden
Offensive bereitgestellt worden sind das
heißt die Ukraine hat sich nicht
verlocken lassen diese Kräfte quasi
entsprechend auszuspielen sondern sie
hat sie immer noch geballt verfügbar für
diese mögliche Offensive die Frage ist
natürlich wo und wann und in welchem
Umfang wird diese Offensive stattfinden
das wären in den nächsten Wochen leben
und auch Erfolg wird davon abhängen ob
es den Ukraine gelingt mit Überraschung
und Täuschung entsprechend durchzustoßen
was wir mitnehmen müssen ist das ist
überhaupt nichts sagen hilft quasi die
Russen lächerlich zu machen deine schade
dass meiner Sicht der Ukraine mehr als
es ihr hilft natürlich hat die Ukraine
auch im Informationsraum ganz klar die
Absicht zu zeigen wie gut und überlegen
Sie auch handeln kann und dass sie den
Initiative zurück gewinnen kann aber sie
dürfen nicht vergessen dass die
russischen Streitkräfte einiges an
Potenzial verfügbar haben ich verweise
hier noch einmal immer auf die Aussagen
auch von hohen US-Militärs die auf das
Hinweisen general karioli habe ich schon
genannt aber auch general Mark Miele und
die zeigen dass es auch tatsächlich die
Russen noch einiges in der Hinterhand
haben das heißt wenn wir wollen dass die
Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt dann muss
sie massiv unterstützt werden denn die
Situation wird nicht einfach vorbeigehen
wenn wir es so machen wie bis jetzt dass
man einfach immer ein bisschen was
liefert in der Hoffnung dass ich das
jetzt ausgeht und wir haben gesehen dass
einzelne Waffensysteme bis jetzt noch
nie das Züge an der Waage waren sondern
zusammen
schaut der unterschiedlichen Fähigkeiten
der möglicherweise eine Bewegung eine
tatsächliche Bewegung in diesem Konflikt
bringen falls nicht wird dieser
konflikter länger andauern
zum Thema Unterstützung da sind die USA
oder auch die anderen Nato-Partner ja
über die Zeit schon der Ukraine immer
weiter entgegengekommen da gab es quasi
rote Linien die überschritten wurden
lange wurde gesagt das werden keine
Kampfjets geliefert jetzt werden
Kampfjets geliefert was müsste denn von
westlicher Unterstützer Seite passieren
dass sie sagen würden das ist eine
angemessene Unterstützung
ja dazu muss man jetzt auch diese
Waffenlieferungen weniger einordnen und
auch hier erzähle ich Ihnen nichts Neues
sondern dass wir das auch immer wieder
intensiv diskutiert auch in
amerikanischen Zirkeln oder auch in
verschiedenen sehr hochkarätig besetzten
Tageszeitungen der Punkt ist dass die
Amerikaner Versuchung wie in einem
Boxkampf die Russen dahingehend zu
besiegen dass sie nicht versuchen das
mit einem k.o zu erreichen sondern mit
einem Punkte sieht das ist mal versucht
Runde für Runde für sich zu entscheiden
sie sehen also sehr gut am Schlachtfeld
wenn es quasi aus einer symmetrischen
Situationen eine asymmetrische kommt
also wenn Russland war sehr erfolgreich
hat dass die Ukraine das bekommen dass
es braucht um wieder eine symmetrische
Situation herzustellen aber leider auch
nicht mehr ich gebe Ihnen ein paar
Beispiele 20 heimersysteme wurden
geliefert die haben einen entscheidenden
Effekt im Sommer erzielt die Ukraine hat
50 bis 100 gefordert die haben sie nicht
bekommen denken Sie an diese
weitreichenden Raketen vom Camps mit 300
km Reichweite die Ukraine hat bekommen
Rakete mit einer Reichweite von 160 km
denken Sie daran an die Diskussion auch
hier hat die USA gesagt der Ball ist
jetzt Europa wenn europäischen
Verbündeten F16 liefern wollen soll es
uns recht sein wir selber liefern
momentan keine F16 denken Sie auch an
den Umstand dass all diese
arschlochkörperpatronen ballistischen
Raketen Ziele treffen die Fliegen alle
mit dem russischen
Satellitennavigationssystem das könnte
man stören oder zerstören das wird aber
nicht gemacht und denken Sie auch an
diesen Abzug bei Personen plötzlich über
drei Brücken die unter dauerbeschuh
standen über Nacht 30.000 russische
Soldaten Fahrzeuge sich abziehen können
das heißt man sieht dass man versucht
quasi den Russen auf lange sich zu
zeigen es macht keinen Sinn die Ukraine
bekommt immer das was sie braucht aber
auch auf der anderen Seite versucht man
das quasi auch nicht zu reizen und das
ist natürlich immer denn es bedeutet
dass der Krieg länger dauert das
bedeutet dass die Ukraine immer wieder
gezwungen ist neue Kräfte aufzustellen
wenn sie mich jetzt fragen würden was
muss passieren damit die Ukraine einen
entscheidenden Erfolg ja durchsetzen
kann so ist es so dass man quasi alle
Komponenten die so moderne Streitkräfte
brauchen abbilden muss und dazu gehört
zum Beispiel auch der Umstand dass die
Ukraine Kampfflugzeuge brauchte eine
funktionierende Luftwaffe nicht nur um
den eigenen Luftraum zu sichern und die
Tiefe des Landes denken Sie an die
laufenden Angriffe der strategischen
Ebene von russischer Seite sondern um
auch die besetzten Gebiete zurück zu
Ohren und um das geht es im Wesentlichen
die Ukraine möchte die von Russland
besetzen Gebiete zurückerobern in der
Grenze wie es von Russland auch in der
letzten Jahren immer wieder bestätigt
worden ist bis zu dem Angriff der
eigentlich schon 2014 passiert ist und
nicht da 2022 wie wir auf den Eindruck
haben Tag des 43 Tage so
vielen Dank dass Sie meine und die Frage
der Community so umfangreich beantwortet
haben vielen Dank
herzlichen Dank für Zeit und Vertrauen
und Liebe Grüße zurück
ich denke wir werden hier mit euch noch
öfter über diese Thematik sprechen denn
sie dauerte jetzt schon an und sie wird
wohl auch noch eine Weile andauernd ich
werfe zum Schluss noch mal einen Blick
in die Kommentare hier schreibt Mathias
gestörtenmeier auf Youtube Markus
Reißner bester Mann also ein Lob für
unseren Experten und hier schreibt Jumpy
auf Youtube wenn ich mir die Lage und
mach Mut anschaue scheinen die Russen
leichte Vorteile zu haben die einen
Kreis im gelingt nicht wirklich im
Zentrum wird vorgerückt hohe Verluste
kann man sich leisten ja wie das Ganze
sich weiterentwickelt in bachmut aber
natürlich auch generell auf dem
ukrainischen Gebiet wir bleiben für euch
dran ich freue mich wenn ihr wieder
einschaltet danke für eure Kommentare
und bis zum nächsten Mal